Uh,
uh,
of the changes since nine 11 have been
positive.
I mean an enormous amount of money has
been thrown at the intelligence
community.
So you,
you went from a period in the 90s where,
uh,
the peace dividend after the cold war
was in many cases taken at the expense
of the intelligence community and there
wasn't much hiring going on and a lot of
early retirements are being forced and
there weren't very many investments and
place,
it really kind of hollowed out after
nine 11,
massive amounts of money were thrown in.
Everybody went on huge hiring sprees and
what you,
I mean,
I don't live inside the community but
touring it and bumping up against it.
What I,
my impression is that immediately after
nine 11,
you had an extraordinarily talented
group of young people volunteer to go
into the intelligence beauty,
probably the best generation of public
servants and went into the government.
You know,
since the 60s,
people were motivated.
They were smart,
they were well educated and they were
committed,
uh,
after nine,
11,
and then they,
but they went into the system.
The system really didn't know how to
absorb them.
And a lot of them bounced out.
A lot of people became disillusioned.
There weren't a good senior programs or
officers available to mentor them.
And so I think that sort of wave of
young people as has been atrophied and
maybe not,
um,
sort of,
brought up to the way,
the way you would win in the meanwhile,
one of their experiences when all these
really great people went in was that the
whole system kept being reorganized and
then reorganized again.
And then the agencies,
we're all moving around.
And so I think the sense you have from
inside is that there's still a lot of
confusion about what is a career in
intelligence.
I mean,
how do you actually have a useful and
successful and interesting career as a,
as an operative.
I mean,
analysts,
you know,
there's millions of analysts running
around.
Um,
but as to the actual collection of
intelligence,
which was what the problem seemed to be
running up to nine 11,
I don't think the system is,
is,
I don't think the system is fixed at
all.
I think it's still a mess.
Yes.
Sorry.
For
private firms,
I think that's a,
I think that's plain.
I think it's,
um,
I don't think that private contractors
ought to be acting on the battlefield as
sort of proxies for or allies of the u s
military.
Um,
I think private contracting for
logistics and for support and for
technology,
um,
and maybe for some analysis,
uh,
can be part of a governmental system,
but to have private contractors in the
field tearing out the,
the sort of state craft of war or
shadowy intelligence,
a warlike activity,
paramilitary or collection activity,
I think is a mistake.
Pardon?
You know,
he's a,
he's a professional who I think was
welcomed there when he was appointed
because the turmoil of the previous
regime had been pretty considerable.
He was a known quantity.
He was known to be sort of a friend of
the CIA,
wasn't there to tear it down or kind of
reinvent it the way some other directors
had,
had come in wanting to do.
But the basic problem that he faces and
that the agency faces is that they
basically had been reorganized out of
their prestige and to some extent
reorganized out of their parts of their
mission.
And you know,
they've lost their place at the table.
Their place at the table with the White
House is now taken by the director of
national intelligence,
the new sort of tsar of all the
intelligence agencies.
And that means the CIA is adjusting to a
completely different world in which it
does.
No,
it no longer has direct contact with the
press of the United States every
morning.
That's what made the CIA the source of
all this mystique in our political
culture was that,
you know,
every morning,
first thing,
six 30 or 7:00
AM the president nodded,
states sits down with the director of
the CIA or his designated briefer and
they talk about the world.
And when the president wants something
done off the books,
uh,
he turns to the CIA and he says
directly,
you know,
I want to,
I want to raid Cuba or I want to foment
a descent in this country or that,
and that relationship of the president
and the CIO is broken.
It just doesn't exist anymore.
The CIA has now more like the FBI at
works at one step removed.
It has a mission to go out into the
world and steal secrets and occasionally
go out in the world and blow up bridges.
But it's doing that almost as a kind of
separate like,
uh,
like,
like the Federal Reserve that does
monetary policy that they're divorced
from,
from policy and decision making or if
there's an intermediary and the DA and
Dni.
And I think Hayden has not been able to
quite resolve how this reorganization
will play out in the,
in the life of the institution.
Well,
there's a very heated debate yeah.
Within the U s army and the military
continuing now,
and I'm still,
I'm doing some work on this now.
Um,
and you know,
the,
the strain,
everyone agrees there was an enormous
strain.
Uh,
the question is,
uh,
that are,
the questions that are debated are what
are the strategic consequences of this
strain.
Um,
and on the one hand you have those like
Casey or a certain colonels and others
who would emphasize the loss of combat
capability,
uh,
the potential for a surprise elsewhere
in the world that the United States
can't respond to.
Um,
and,
and the general sort of inability of the
United States to say pivot from Iraq
where things may be going better to
Afghanistan,
where things are clearly going worse
because there just is no,
there's no elasticity in the,
in the system anymore.
The resources are all on the,
in the field.
So that's one side.
The other side emphasizes as gates did
and a speech a couple of weeks ago,
look,
we have armies to win the wars that
we're in.
And you know,
I would rather break an army winning,
uh,
the war that we have to win than worry
about some future scenario.
Nobody this.
So somebody was arguing with her the
other day.
I says,
you know,
nobody worried during World War II that
we were going to break the army and
overemphasize figuring out how to beat
Nazi Germany.
And then we were going to miss Vietnam
because we hadn't prepared for
counterinsurgency.
No,
you,
that's what you have armies for is to go
all out to achieve the objectives you
need to achieve now.
So then that depends on whether you
believe finishing in Iraq with every,
uh,
brigade available is really in the
national interest.
Uh,
and that,
and so in the end,
these arguments about strain and
breaking the army,
uh,
there are kind of coded argument about
whether the rock is still worthwhile.
I think the hud still important for a
lot of them
reasons.
Uh,
you know,
starting with justice,
the fact that he's,
you know,
at large and,
and has more or less accepted
responsibility for the attacks and no
one's ever bothered to chase him down.
Um,
but more sort of relevant to the current
scene.
This,
we talked before about the 20 years of
continuous leadership,
the ability to deliver messages to
followers,
to define the narrative of the war that
he believes he's leading to identify
targets to name countries,
but he's still matters.
It doesn't matter the way he did in
1999,
but taking him off the airwaves and
forcing al-Qaida to deal for the first
time in 20 years with a succession
crisis,
probably from the point of view of
alcaide his adversaries would be a good
objective.
Um,
so I think there are lots of reasons why
the,
the hunt for him still matters as to
what al Qaeda is capability is,
uh,
this year.
Um,
I think all you can really do is look at
what the system is reporting by way of
kind of threat reporting on the one
hand,
and then what all the open source
evidence from the last three or four
years tells you about their capability.
And I think that in summary,
what it tells you is that they still
have the intent to carry out what you
might think of as sort of medium sized,
uh,
attacks against airplanes,
against,
uh,
subway systems against embassies,
military bases.
They have the capability to plan sort of
six to nine month,
fairly complicated,
fairly ambitious plans like the one
that's on trial in London involving the
attempt to blow up planes over the
Atlantic in August of 2006,
the one that led to us not being able to
carry our toothpaste board airplanes,
that was their most ambitious plots
since nine 11.
It was meant to be the fifth anniversary
plot.
It was meant to take down five to 10
planes.
If it's exceeded,
you'd have,
we'd be living in a different world.
There'd be 600 or more dead Americans
and Brits lying in the Atlantic Ocean
and we'd probably be occupying the
federally administered tribal areas and
in engaged in a very vicious,
a counter insurgency campaign.
But that's been their most ambitious
plot since.
And it's,
it's a couple of orders of magnitude
short of nine 11.
So I think they'll probably,
I mean,
bin Ladin keeps an eye.
Al Kind keeps an eye on the calendar.
They know this is an election season.
I think he'll probably want to do
something in 2004 what we can see in
retrospect is that he didn't have the
capability to do anything other than a
media event,
but he appeared like an apparition on
the weekend before the election and
delivered this message to the American
people.
John Kerry's still believes that this
day was a factor in his defeat in a
close election.
So at a minimum,
I expect them to attempt media events,
but if they have capability of,
they'll probably will use it during the
fall season.
Yeah.